[Musique]
le roi arthur revient
si vous faites des passages je sais pas
ce que vous ferez il y aurait moyen de
réduire la voilure sur la connaît il
veut dire ça dans le bon sens du terme
camelot premier volet vous faites deux
cent pas sur le chemin et vous monter la
garde au cas où quelqu'un approche
approche son chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et s'il ya
personne qui approche je prends revient
non vous monter la garde
au cinéma le 21 juillet
le roi arthur vient vous êtes de retour
et ça c'est vraiment une bonne nouvelle
pour nous tous un bien sûr mais surtout
pour le peuple breton qui arnaquent ans
est sérieusement tire la langue c'est à
dire c'est métaphorique petit tir pas
littéralement tous la langue
sont au bout du rouleau bras
séparé n'était pas c'est pas
littéralement un gros rouleau avec des
jambes camelot premier volet voilà
maintenant si vous ne sentez pas vous le
sentez pas au cinéma le 21 juillet
arthur pendragon
un bien pas bien long non convaincu mais
en disant qu'on a plus vu son pif il et
cannelle fils pont dragon c'est tous
évidemment qu'il est pas mort ça fait
dix ans qu'ils vivront salsifis mon dieu
par tous les saints non non non non non
commencés pas je suis absolument pas
royer pas besoin de se lever
à seignosse lors retrouver le jeu vous
fait tous prendre le palais partie bravo
alors c'est très constructif
la résistance ça vous dit quelque chose
allait
organiser ça pouvait être intéressant
d'organiser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la résistance vous
entendez quelque chose et anti lgv avec
une boîte tonding nba vous entendu
quelque chose pour faire quelque chose
de complètement informel c'est pas
possible d'être largué voilà
comment ça se passe cette petite
résistance
bon vous faites deux cent pas sur le
chemin et vous monter la garde au cas où
quelqu'un approche approche sans un
chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et s'il ya
personne qui approchent suprend revient
non vous monter la garde
il y aurait moyen de réduire la voilure
sur la connerie
de fils pendragon est de retour en bacs
qui viennent
il faut tuer arthur vous savez pas faire
ça entraîner les troupes
les sièges
il faisait pas français
bah oui mais l'entrée n'est pas des
débiles si j'entre à des débiles mais
pas des débiles comme ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par vous êtes de retour dès fois que
vous redevenir roi quoi oui oui basse et
c'est vrai que ça fait envie quoi voir
maintenant si vous le sentez pas vous
sentez pas